Let's go next to our color from the six, four,
six area code.
Who's calling today from six 46.
Hey, David, this is Chris.
How you doing?
Hey Chris, how are you?
Good.
So this is in response to your, hey, Trump
is just telling me the truth video, which
sort of felt like a, uh, like a call to arms
almost for, um, for Donald Trump supporters
to sort of admit that he's a racist.
Is that a correct assumption of the dcis of
the video?
No.
I mean, the, the point was not so much to
get the Trumpists to admit that Trump is a
racist, but it's more importantly, it wasn't
to every Trumpist.
I was not implying every Trumpist is racist,
but the ones who are should just say, yeah,
I like Trump's xenophobic rhetoric.
Just tell me, you know.
Right.
So sort of what I'm going at is that it's
been a really common strategy among the Democrats
to label their opposition as racist.
And my fear is that this is sort of gonna
fall under deaf ears.
Like you use the word fatigue.
I think that's the perfect word to use in
this situation as well.
So basically my question is can the Democrats
win on a platform of labeling up opposition
as racists or will this fall under deaf ears
for the moderator?
Yeah.
So the, I disagree with the premise of your
question because nobody is s I've not seen
any of the candidates currently running for
the 2020 Democratic primary where I could
say their platform is to call Trump and his
supporters racist.
So this in sense I reject the, the sort of
foundation of your question.
That being said, I do think that you are correctly
pointing out that merely alleging racism is
not a political strategy and that you need
to be able to connect with voters on more
than that, particularly because there are
lots of racist and xenophobic voters.
So this, this is sort of my point, you and
I, we may disagree on the degree to which
calling people racist is democratic strategy,
but it sounds like you and I agree that it
is not a good political strategy to the extent
that anyone is employing it.
Well, even like with Kamala Harris, she really
heavily went after Joe Biden over the bus
issue.
Yeah.
Where it felt like that was sort of the central
point of what she was trying to accomplish
through the debate.
Yeah.
It was totally calculated and it worked in
terms of optics, but there was, it was clear
that it was a complete calculation that had
been made ahead of time.
Okay.
Right.
But don't you agree that the candidates, like
if you look at their Twitter, I remember yesterday
Bernie Sanders is like, we must admit that
we have a Zita phobic and racist president,
Blah Blah, blah.
This is a very common thing we're seeing more
and more of and I'm just worried that that's
going to alienate the moderates.
Yeah, I mean listen, it's going to alienate
the racists for sure.
And I think you're right that if there is
a sort of sway, a bl middle in terms of the
election, if all they feel like they're seeing
from candidates is allegations that Trump
is racist, it's not going to be particularly
good.
But to be clear, my message on, I think it
was Monday, maybe it was Tuesday, Tuesday,
my message was not about running a campaign
about Trump is a racist.
It's, I would just respect Trumpists who are
xenophobic and racist much more if they came
clean about why they like Trump instead of
couching it as economic or trade policy or
whatever else.
That's all it was.
It was not by any means suggesting Democrats
run a campaign based on Trump is racist.
Where's the, it's also hard for people to
understand that because every single speech
that Trump does, he talks about how good the
economy is doing for marginalized groups,
like black people and Latino people.
So on one year they're hearing people saying
that their candidate is a racist, but then
on their other ear, they're hearing the candidate
himself talk about how good the lives of black
people and Latino people are.
So it's confusing.
Well, that's the case in politics all the
time.
The debt is up, the debt is down, the deficit
is up, the deficits down.
We're winning the war in Iraq.
We're never should've been in Iraq.
I mean debt that's not particularly new.
The fact that voters are hearing literally
opposite stories from different people in
politics.
That's, that's a, that's politics.
Right?
So what you're saying is, um, I guess the
thesis of what I was asking was do you think
this could alienate moderates?
And you're saying, I'm working on a false
premise.
Uh, w could, what Ailey?
Well, you said, do I think that Democrats
running on Trump is racist, could alienate
moderates.
My response was, I don't really think any
candidate is running on that, although candidates
are talking about Trump's Sinophobia.
Okay, great.
I mean, I completely disagree, but thanks
for having the conversation about it.
All right, Chris, appreciate the call.